ben c'est parti la compil de 9 ans de
génériques de tomber de thé poupée voici
les principaux titres de notre qualité
d'abord d'une cote
qu'est ce que tu fais là jean-claude
c'est pas de 20 heures mais non c'est
pas du tout 20 heures là c'est touche
pas à mon poste france 4 à la célèbre
émission qui cartonne louis basse et ça
ça démarre ce soir je disputerai pas
jean claude bourret c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sarah que ce que nous avons toujours à
mon poste c'est neuf ans neuf ans
d'émission alors y'en a qui sont arrivés
dernièrement dans un instant vous avez
donné une image qui vous a le plus
marqué pendant ces neuf ans et en 9 ans
tpm paix on va être honnête il s'en est
passé plein de choses d'ailleurs il
s'est passé tellement de choses qu'on a
du mal à tout retenir regarder on vous a
préparé un petit magnéto récapitulatif
en chiffres des neuf ans tpv regarde me
vende ppm fait
1351 c'est le nombre d'émissions de tpm
paix qui ont déjà vu le jour
[Applaudissements]
deux mille sept cent trente huit heures
de programmes pour vous faire quitter
une bonne barca ce soir
deux millions c'est le record d'audience
que nous avons atteint le 21 avril 2016
franchement j'ai kiffé donc 90 et le
nombre approximatif de chroniqueurs
ayant passé plus ou moins de temps sur
le plateau ils sont là aujourd'hui et
pmp c'est aussi près de 5000 invités
beaucoup d'amis mais pas que 18 plateau
ruinés par des surprises
[Musique]
douze numéros de téléphone dévoilé à
l'antenne avec un grand gagnant benjamin
castaldi un drame pour cyril j'ai perdu
une dent 453 levée de jambes d'isabelle
parfois imité mais jamais égalé
non mais c'est de 380 coup de gueule de
gilles verdez je trouve qu'elle est
[Applaudissements]
ouvert
vous n'y connaissez rien
mais vous
70 gobelet collée sur le front de cyril
là on se régale 1,93 petit je suis beau
b
[Musique]
bref et pmp c'est une émission bien rodé
malgré les 10500 loupé avec un objectif
à 1500e ce serait pas mal
je sais pas si on va y arriver mais bon
[Applaudissements]